dear
friends
you are
our big friends
a
deep and um
in ukraine
present
friends of ukraine
polish and lithium president
they came here to support ukraine in a
very difficult time
and we appreciate it very much
these are the partners who support
ukraine
not just in words but also by their
actions
and
they help us to increase
our capacity in military area
they help us to provide
a
defense
equipment
and
is the assistant that um ukrainian
military need and i'm
very grateful to
both our presidents that are present
here
polish and lysanian diplomats stay here
and they continue their work it's
an important signal to us
and we appreciate a quick reaction
regarding
recognition from russia of the so-called
independent states in lugansk and years
we
have
mutual
understanding
and this is
an aggression against ukraine against
our sovereignty against
our independence
and
presence of russia
on the territory of our temporarily
occupied and bath
he is
understood as
leaving
the minsk agreement on art of russia
that is i mean
threatening the conflict and password
and the reaction to these
actions
should be
immediate
and hard
the european union has already proved
sanctions against russia
the same was done by the usa
uk
canada
a very important decision was made by
germany as well
and this project of weapons
must be stopped
because against ukraine but also against
war
we believe that
future of european
security is
now being decided here at home in
ukraine and coordinating our efforts
to
de-escalate the conflict
one of the important issues is to ensure
full work of um our
ce work
to prevent any provocation and
escalations we count on
the uh
polish presidency in
oste
and we're thankful for the um
regular meeting of
osce
meeting
i'm grateful to the presidents of
lithuania
and to the president of poland
that your beautiful countries
are the first states
who acknowledged european
prospects for ukraine
and
they feel convinced that we shouldn't
support this vote
and
european union could support ukraine now
in these difficult
conditions we spoke a lot about it and
we think
an important signal for ukrainian
community
or unite in our state
i believe our dear presidents
share this point of view
and
we bought
support from them
for ukraine to be a candidate to become
a member of eu
ungrateful
our today's meeting proved
that poland and lithuania are standing
shoulder bash through the review pram
and we appreciate it
our dear friends thank you
[Music]
erosion
foreign
m
m
is willing to join the european union
as we
oh
we will support
escalation
of nato alliance
are very
serious european aspirations
it is now time for us the eu countries
to give way forward to ukraine
and ready
is
[Music]
foreign
um
i think this is
foreign
[Music]
russian science
european countries united all the
countries around the world
of condemnation
of the world but that is not enough
those decisions
[Music]
is
is
destroys the entire security
architecture that we have lived with
very dangerous
the international community and russia
itself so i would truly welcome if
russia understood the consequences of
its likely behavior
direct its actions to peace corporation
and peaceful cohabitation that's what i
wish for
observing
uh
is
is
is
everyone has to make specific stories
so unfortunately
[Music]
new opportunities in different parts of
the world
uh
foreign
architecture
architecture
foreign
[Music]
ukrainians
it's a question of negotiation not
putting
it
with the questions
foreign
is
we have to close
yes
uh
the same way
security this is why
and that is
this is how it worked in the past this
is how it works today and this is how it
will work in the future
foreign
foreign